can I say something I'm 44 years old and
you just attacked me with your 44 years
old that's why you're single right that
was really not good I never said that
was yeah
I said you don't even know what happened
it doesn't matter bro like bro we're
talking about something else and now
you've jumped into no no the whole
conversation to be about you no no it's
not it's about maybe trying to
in here but I don't have to try nothing
bro oh Lord okay
oh Lord like bro you can say that as
many times as you want it no because
it's heavy for her yeah I mean bro okay
yeah but life yeah I'm saying look he
was just honest yeah and all the men in
here are thinking it nobody wants a 44
year old I'm gonna be honest she's right
here like that's me hold on wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
hold a king Rich hold on a second this
is the problem with modern women you
think I'm wondering yeah you think Fox
and blatant obvious things are obvious
is being rude this is a problem No No
One's Gonna want her because
no no no no no hold on no one said No No
One's Gonna want her okay you see no no
go on go I'm gone see what I'm saying
that's where the problem lies bro like
you a lot of times you not find it hard
to follow what was actually said all
right you go with what you feel was said
well I'm not finished bro
bro like
bruh just compose yourself everyone
composed even including me everyone
composes no I'm speaking bro now let him
land let's say what he said at the end
of the day yeah a lot of times women
find it hard to hear the truth yeah a
lot of times women will prefer to hear
lights
you get what I'm saying and then when
when guys come out and when guys finally
feel like this is a safe place where I
can actually be real with you now is
shaming or you're hating you're being
horrible things the way you said it
maybe a few nights
and this goes back to the unrealistic
expectations
bro stop interrupting bro I've not
finished when I finish you can have your
chance to speak
I don't care like this is my show bro
like I'm not trying to be horrible but
you are just being like Oh I'm gonna I'm
just gonna jump in when I like no it
don't go like that bro
I swear seriously
guys
this is just crazy like they will never
come back but listen at the end of the
day bro yeah
um guys are not allowed to air or or um
thoughts on the women that we're dating
you know the critiques and we're just
not really allowed to tell the truth but
when it's time to tell guys that they're
too short they're too broke they're too
ugly their Willies are small or they're
lame they haven't got enough clout
they're not funny enough they're boring
blah blah blah it's everywhere and
everybody laughs including men men will
laugh at other men yeah they idea with
like we I'm yet to see the video where
women are dissing women about real
serious things and every women around
there collectively alike yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's funny no rap guess what when
I'm if anybody calls a woman fat that's
fat shaming yeah if I'm sorry if a man
calls women fat that's fat shaming yeah
but when it's time to laugh at men and
call them fat everybody laughs brother
there's no fat shaming there bro that's
a clear indicator guess what in TV that
we got um shows like The Simpsons family
guy all these other shows that are
mainstream where it's depicting taking
the mick out of men that are fat what
about their feelings bro it's still
funny man yeah she didn't hear what I
said she said it's still fat shaving
listen bro you're not listening bro I am
yet to see a cartoon yeah on mainstream
TV where it depicts a fat woman and
everyone's laughing at her and it's just
constantly fat jokes at the fat woman
but it doesn't exist yeah because women
would be supporting other women it
doesn't exist there's a reason why
because it's all right to tear down men
and make men feel inadequate but as soon
as you say something even if it is
factual about a woman is hating or
shaming that is the fact this is the
society we're in I'm not saying it's
your fault I'm not saying it's your
fault I'm not saying any of you that's
full but I'm saying this is the right
Society we're in and when you defend it
that just goes to show that you really
don't have no comprehension of what men
go through in this society and you're
only looking at it from your own point
of view and as I said like a lot of
times when women are critiqued and they
and people say oh that's shaming you
can't say that men will join in and and
and and support that that's what I'm
saying can I ask a question please go
ahead so would you feel like we over
would you feel like as women we Overlook
for men like what we don't take serious
so for example you mentioned um fat
Shaman right what do you feel like we
Overlook for men
like just just everything in general
okay like for instance yeah the number
one thing um boom a guy needs to be
making XMR if he's not taking me here
there then I don't want none bro do you
know in this world to make money is hard
bro listen I've been broke before
serious like sleeping on a mattress in
my friend's room this is when I was in
America at College yeah yeah sleeping on
a dirty mattress on my friend's floor if
if it wasn't for my teammate yeah I
would have been a homeless brat wow you
get what I'm saying like I like and if I
say I was trying to move to you at that
time you don't care
you don't know
all right all right all right
all right
all right cool nope you personally okay
not you personally yeah no but I
understand because
okay okay
stop talking they can't hear listen at
the end of the day you just said after
all of that oh you don't know that you
just said I understand because you know
that in general women are not trying to
mess with guys that are broke no as a
human you wouldn't want to it doesn't
matter yeah but that is the fact that
it's true yeah but at the end it's true
no matter why it's true all right and
then also women tend to not really want
to date guys that are sure is that not
like a general consensus that women want
short of money short in height
vertically challenged do you know what
that depends on some women I feel like
if you plus a guy's high on their
qualities and how they are as a person
not everyone
[Music]
are allowed to choose what they want
like you're allowed to want a tall man
there's nothing wrong with that nobody
same way same way you would want a
specific girl with specific things you
are allowed to have that no sheep for
example what's your name baby girl
Jessica Jessica I can't tell you
otherwise
okay you know what I mean
like you're allowed to choose what you
want that's what I'm saying well I never
said you're not allowed to choose what
you want so what's your point
I'm saying you're allowed to choose what
you want so if you want why are you
telling me if you want a tall man or if
you want to change the topic real quick
you're not you're not understanding this
is what I'm saying you lot don't
understand help me understand okay let
me finish yeah can I ask a question real
quick though let him finish you
it just with that which is a point that
I don't know why you made that point
because I never said people are not
allowed to choose what they want I never
said that what I stated is that at the
end of the day like when it comes to
critiques of people especially on things
that are out of the person's control
yeah height is out of a man's control
the size of his Willy is out of control
you know what I'm saying how attractive
he is if he's a Tyrone uh an average guy
or sub five that's obvious control
really and truly yeah of course as many
of you know I was just banned on Tic Tac
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible